では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは本当は結構難しいんですから
結構早く終わりにします
まあ一応タイトルはそういうタイトルで
中道の安楽を実感するために
まあ中道という話なんですね
なんか言葉を聞いただけで
なんだ中道かというね
よくわかっているような錯覚を起こしてしまいます
しかし ブッダの言葉っていうのはね
かなり大変深い真理を語られてますから
簡単に理解できそうに見えるんだけど
本当はそうでもありません
はい まあそういうことで
すべてはデジタル デジタルですね
すべてのものはデジタルだというテーマでまず考えてみましょう
物質 仏教 物質というのは地水火風という 4つのエネルギーの流れなんですね
で なんで地水火風というのかというと
まあただ土水火風だと思ったっても構いませんませんよというね
難しいことはわからない人々は一般的にまあそんなものだと思ったってもいいんじゃないのかということで
そういう単語を使っているんです
地水火風にしたっても
まあ一応流れているもので固定はしないんですね
一応本物の地水火風っていうのは
この素粒子のレベルで起きる
もっと深いところで起きるエネルギーの流れなんです
だから物質は全部そういうものなんです
それで流れる場合は生滅という波なんですね
であの なんかおかしいんだけどね
この素粒子の世界ではね
この生まれては消え 生まれては消えという波があるんです
で これ絶えず起こるんだから
この科学の世界では波という言葉使いますけど
生まれては消えっていうことは使わないんですね
それわからないでしょうね
おそらく 波がなぜあるのかというと
この生まれて消えて生まれて消えていくんだから
その波なんですね だから物質は変化するし
あの光合っていうかね
そういうこともできるしね
それで一旦元素 2つ メス 4つ合わせて別なものを作っちゃうと
前のものとは全く関係ない新しいものが生まれたりするしね
ですから どこかで消えて消えることはありますけど
科学世界ではそれはなかなか概念はないんですね
なめていたってもずっとあるものだと思ってしまうんですね
とにかく地水火というのは生と滅の波であって
注釈やら仏典になってくると
このこの生と滅の間に十というステップも入れているんですね
まあどうしたことはない
波の場合は 波の始まるところと終わるところと
ピークのところというね
メス考えられますから
一応物質の流れをアビダルマ論ではちゃんとした長い波で考えているんですね
ですから この十のセクションは少々長いんです
お釈迦様の古い経典では
まあ生滅だけで終わっています
波であることには変わりはありませんね
十があってもなくても
物質は波なんですね それで今日は書いてないんだけど
我々の心も同じなんです
生まれては消え 生まれては消え
生まれては消え どうもこの消えることっていうのは実感できないんですね
これがかなり問題なんです
ですから 私知ってますよ
ちょっと 10分前の自分の心と今の自分の心は違いますよと
泣いている時の自分の心と笑っている時の自分の心が随分違いますよ
自分の子供を見る時の心と
窓から外を見る時の心というのはものすごく違うんです
だからそのようにものすごい心が変わるんだけど
変わるためには前の心は消えなくてはいけないでしょ
この消えるとこわからないんですね
で 今日はアニメーションを入れたんで
スライドに 必ず消えるんです
それが 見えますかね 生まれては消えないんです
現れては消えないんですけど
ワンセット じーっと見ているとワンセットの消えは見えるかもしれませんだけど
ワンセットの中でも生まれては消えでなきゃアニメーションにならないんです
でも変化しているということは
なんとなく変わってるんだっていうことは知ってるんだけど
この消えるってことはなかなか見えないんですね
この我々の弱みをうまく使って
世界はね いろんなことをやっているんです
あの弱みをなくそうではないです
世界は 弱みをうまく使うと
というなんかずるがこいやり方なんですね
物質を知る私たちに知られるのはまるまるがあるかないかですね
はい これよりちょっと難しくないんです
我々はこんな地水火風も知りませんし
ただ部屋があるかとかね
机があるとかね まあそんな程度の知ることは知ってます
それからないっていうことも知ってます
例えば この椅子には誰が座っている？このコーナーの椅子には誰もいないと
そのあるなしは知ってます
その程度のあるなしは知ってますけど
今日の難しいポイントはないは知り得ないんです
これを覚えておいてください
理解できなくても まあ知らないんです
私は どうしようもないんです
覚えておいてください
私たちにはあるということは知ることはできます
ないということは知り得ないんです
データがないと心に入っても
無であるならば 何の反応もないの
なんかちょっと文章を間違ってますね
データがないと データがない状態で心はもう認識しようとしていますけど
何も入ってないんですね
何も入ってないんだったから
入ってないんだから認識は起こりません
あ 後で書いてないならば
あのわかりやすく説明します
データが自分の瞬間であると認識します
例えば この部屋に音があったら聞こえる
音がなかったら何を聞こえる？音がないことを聞こえますかね
そういう簡単なことなんです
音があるならばあると知っています
音がないならばないと知らないんです
その時 心は別なこと あるものに聞こえするんです
もし音が全くない防弾
なんて言いますか 防音の部屋にいる場合は
我々は部屋を見ているんです
あるいは突然喋り出します
心はあるというものを欠けているんですね
だからないということは認識不可能です
というか 認識しないんです
ですから 知識とはすべてあるの連続です
我々知っている世界というのはすべてある
ある ある あるという連続なんです
皆様方はこの椅子を見たら
あ この椅子に誰もいないと言うでしょ
だから あ なるほど 人がいないことは知ったんじゃない
どうですかね ただ 誰も座っていない椅子をちょっと見て
ちょっと難しいところですから
ちょっと見てチェックしてください
誰もいない椅子がありますと
それで椅子に人がないということを認識できる
ちょっと怪しいんですよ
我々は椅子があると認識する
この場合は 人がないということは比較的に考えられますが
認識をしないんです よくいないことは
この件でわかります ある部屋で人が座っている
椅子もあります で その人が頼みます
あの 例えば何を頼みますかね
まああの ミネラルウォーター一つ買って
こう自動販売機で買ってきて買ってきてくださいと
喉が渇いてるんだと それでその人はさっさと自動販売機を探していって
下がっていって もうやっと見つけて
ミネラルウォーター 1本買ってまた来るんです
来て部屋にあったら あら
人がいないと その人はもういないんです
その時 はっきりと人がいないことを認識するんです
で どういう認識かというと
そうっと人がいるんだ
そうと部屋に座ってミネラルウォーターを飲もうと待っている人がいるんだよという固定概念があって
ドアを開けてみたら その固定概念破れちゃったんです
いないんです で その認識は
あの前の認識 前にただ前に
かつて過去で正しいと思っていたことが正しくないと証明されただけであって
人がいないことを認識したわけじゃないんです
だからちょっと不安になるんです
その時はあ どこどこ どこへ行ったの？もう水を持ってこいと言ったのは結構長い
もう 3分 10分もかかったのに
自動販売機を探すためにとかね
で 不安になって どこにいるんですかね
トイレにでも行ったんでしょうかねとかね
不安であることを探すんです
あ いないんだ まあいいやということにならないでしょ
水を欲しいと言ったんだから
机の上に置いておいて
じゃあ帰りますと 気にしないんだということにならないんですよ
どこに行ったのか この人はとかね
だからあるないということは認めたくないんです
固定概念で その人はあるはずでしたから
もうあってほしいんですね
それでその人はのこのこと帰ってくると
はあって安心するんです
やっと固定概念はもう
また 何て言いますか 成立しましたと
そういうすごいシンプルな例で覚えておいてください
ないっていうことは認識しないんです
認識できないんです 例えば
聴覚が起こるために音がドンガンガンぶつからないと耳に
聞こえないんです 味わうためにも味がガンガン舌にぶつかってくらないと
それで光の情報が大量に目にぶつけてくれないと
視覚は生まれません だから五感に激しく情報がものすごい激しく触れてるんです
触れるというか ぶつかってるんです
いつでも情報が情報に叩かれてるんです
それで認識がずっと生まれてるんです
しかし そのすべての認識は生滅変化する波のある時の認識だけなんです
だから 生と住と滅という波なんですね
それの住のところだけ
波のピークのところだけ
って見ているんです 無は引き算です
それも無です でもなんとなく無か無いか分かっているようなんでしょ
あの この前の列の右 私の右側
皆様の左側の椅子には誰もいないんですね
知ってるでしょ？でも人がいないということは知らないんです
椅子があることを知ってるんです
そこで椅子があって 椅子に人がいることから引き算するんですね
引き算したって答えはプラスですけど
マイナスになりません
椅子プラス人引く椅子
なんです ですから この引き算して人がいないと言うんです
しかし 経験ではありません
それは推測です ですから
ものがある 心がある 魂がある
神がいる 私がいる 他人がいるなどのデータは理解するんです
だから人間に何かわかりやすく言いたければ
あるあるあるの話でないと
理解できないんです だって
微塵も証拠ないのに 人類の中でも 90%ぐらい人々は神がいると信じているんだから
微塵も証拠はないんです
それで証拠を出せよ 出そうと神が信仰している人々は頑張ると
神がないないということの結果が出てくるんです
それですっごく困るんです
みんな 怯えたり困ったり
もう大変です 西洋思想史なんか読んでみてください
むちゃくちゃなんですね
ちょっと誰かが神っていうのは人間作ったものだと言っただけで
偉大な哲学者というんですね
どうってことないんだけど
あの西洋のね あのベルトルッソーみたいにね
まあかなりの一流の哲学者たちがいて
神はないというね いないと
エティーストたちですね
無神論者たち すごい哲学者ですって
褒めること どうってことないんだけど
本当は だからこの我々にとってはあるということが納得いきますね
皆様の本当に素晴らしい魂はと言ったら
随分分かったような気がするんですね
全然魂は何かと何も探ったこともないんです
やっぱりあるある話が随分気に入るんです
あるの哲学で生きているんです
あるとされるものに愛着も憎しみも起こるんです
問題はそれなんです あなたに魂がある
あると言ったら あると思いますよと簡単に思うんですね
言った時点で 私の魂だからって
もうすぐ愛着が生まれてくる
憎しみも同じことで あちらには性格の悪い人がいると
いるんだからね だから憎しむんです
ですから 仏教が語るこの煩悩は
あるという問題から生まれるんです
貪瞋痴 それからたくさんありますよ
千義百ですからね 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみとかね 後悔とか情交と
物惜しみ ケチ へつらいなどなど
いっぱいあります ごまかし
そういうのは一つもない場合は成り立たないでしょ
あるんだからなんですね
何が？例えば見栄を張る
自分がいるんだから見栄を張っているんであって
相手がいるんだから相手に対して見栄を張るんであって
見栄を張ることも一つの煩悩なんです
そこで現象は 3つのステップでできています
生まれるステップ 住するステップとなくなるというね
この 3段階の現象で 1段階しか知らないんですね
だから動物を見る場合は
顔だけ見るか 胴体だけ見るか
尾っぽだけ見るかという
永久的にもう動物は何者か全体的には見えなくなるんですね
まあ例えば猫の人間には顔しか見えないならば
我々が知っている猫っていうのは顔だけの存在になるんです
これは見えるものにはちょっとややこしいんだけど
あのクジラもよく喋って話してるでしょ
シャチも鳴いたりする声があるしね
で ゾウさんもね もう結構喋ってますけど
人間にはゾウさんがずっと黙っているように
黙っている生命体なんですね
生き物なんですね そうじゃないんです
結構喋ってるんだそうです
しかし 残念ながらかなり低音
なんです この音波が低いんだから
人間の耳に聞こえないんです
それからドッグヴィジルという笛があるんです
犬笛 で 犬を調教する人々は
このドッグヴィジル 犬笛を使うんです
その笛を吹いても音がないんです
しかし 犬が飛んでくるんです
どういうこと？笛吹いたら音が出ますけど
あれはハイフリークエンシー超音波なんですね
人間に聞こえないんです
ですから 舞台で犬笛を並んで演奏やっても何も聞こえないでしょ
音があるのに そうすると
あなた方何やってるの？もうちゃんと演奏しなさいよと
と言うかもしれませんよ
すると向こうが我々演奏していますよと
ちゃんと呼吸 曲をやってますよと
しかし あれは犬笛でやっているならば聞こえないんです
そういうことで 我々はそういうことは存在もしないことにするんですね
もう思考の題材になりません
それで現象には生 住 滅というステップ 3つあるのに
我々は住だけしか知らないんです
だから人間というのはいつでも物事はあるんだ
私がいるんだ 魂があるんだ
神がいるんだという自我があるんだという
もう邪見にもうものすごく徹しているんです
いくらいくら仏教の話を聞いても
無我なんかは理解できるわけじゃないんです
それで研究する方々は頭だけで研究するんだから
もうなんか怪しいんだと
お釈迦様は無我と言ったっても
それ違うんじゃない？という態度なんです
だって他の哲学者たちはみんな実体論我があるんだと言ってるんだから
だからお釈迦様もやっぱりあると言わなきゃ困ると
それで強引に無理にブッダの言葉を解説するんです
五蘊は無我だと言ったんだけど
我がないと言ってないんだよと
偉そうなことを言うんですけど
その言葉が屁理屈だとわかってないんです
なぜかというと このブッダの理論
論理方法はありますから
ブッダには我がないと言えないんです
が がと主語を使えないでしょうに
ないものだから だから色は無我であるとは言えます
色は現象として認識できるんだからね
それは無我であると言えます
だから認識できるものはすべて無我と言っているんだから
認識できないものは我だと言えないでしょうね
認識できないんだから
認識したこともないんだから
だからそういうへりくつですよ
はい それは皆様にあまり関係ない難しいところですから
まあどうでもいいんですが
あの 我々にとっては もう我々誰でも私がいる
私に魂がある 私に我があるという
前提で生きているんです
生まれつき仏教徒であってもしょうがないんです
実体論にしがみついているんです
それでもうちょっと別な言葉で考えてください
ものがあるものしか認識不可能ですから
生命のこれ 根本的な誤りなんです
一人二人の間違いではないんです
生命たるものは根本的にあるという前提で生きているんです
ないはマイナスあるなんですね
なので また怒り 欲などの感情の種になるんです
では あるんだから執着が生まれますね
私に魂があるならば 大事な魂というふうに執着が生まれるってくる
ない場合は執着生まれないでしょうね
生まれないんですが 我々のないっていうのはマイナスあるなんです
それがもったいないんです
例えば金がないなんです
金がない だからあるはずの金がない
だから悲しいんです 金がないということは別に悲しい
なんで悲しいんですかね
それがあるはずの金がなんです
それはない だから引き算でしょ
マイナスあるでしょ だからまた悲しみやら怒りやら思う
起きてきますね そこで自分がすごく嫌な人がいる
ずっと自分に邪魔をして
迷惑をかけて足を引っ張っていて
もうもうものすごい嫌な人が
その人はもう死んじゃう
清々するんですね 気分がいいんです
煩悩なんです だから必ずしも人が死んだら悩むということではないんです
敵が死んだら楽しいでしょうね
例えば北朝鮮でね 金正日さんを暗殺して
民主主義国家になったら
皆様方お祭りするでしょう
しないと思う？私はすると思いますよ
大変 もう国を挙げて祭りする可能性あります
あの人が死んだことを
だからないということも煩悩を引き起こすんです
本来は引き起こさないはずなんです
例えばここら辺に書けているモネの絵画がどう思い切れたと思う？何も思わないでしょ
ないんだからね もしここら辺でモネの絵がぶら下がってあって
さっさと誰かが持っていっちゃうと
煩悩が生まれるんです
あ 絵画がなくなったと
これ微妙に聞こえるんですけど
これ大胆な話なんです
この微妙なところを理解すれば
皆様 すっごく頭がいい人間になりますよ
もう西洋哲学はもの遥かに超えちゃいます
だから我々は認識するないはマイナスあるです
だから憎しみ 嫉妬 欲などなどが当然生まれてくるんです
例えば人ががんになる
怖いんですね 知り合いだったら本当に悲しくなっちゃうんですね
それで手術して これ取り出してきれいになくなったと
で あ よかったよかったねとかね
喜んじゃうでしょ あれ
ないものを喜んでるでしょ
どんなないもの あるものがなくなったんですね
いわゆる嫌なものがなくなったんだから
もう欲が生まれているんです
そこで好きなものなくなると悲しみが生まれてくるんです
だから私たちにとっては
あると認識しても 心がずっと汚れちゃうんです
ないと認識してもすーっと汚れるんです
本来はないということは認識するとどうってことないはずなんです
これはあまりいい例えではなかったんですけどね
あの フィルムは光に反応して変化を起こすんですね
で 暗闇で撮った写真は現像すると透明なフィルムになるんです
なんかフィルムと同じっていうことでね
例えば昔のカメラでね
フィルムが入ってるカメラで写真撮る場合は
光がないと写真撮れないんですね
これでダークルームに行ってシャッターを押して現像してみても
フィルムが全部溶けちゃいます
薬は ただ あのセロ セルロイドのあれ
あれだけ残っちゃう データ取られてないんです
光データが入ったらそこら辺で化学反応起きちゃって
あの 銀でしたっけ？あの銀の素粒子が残るんです
そこでそのフィルムをプリントしてみるとどうなりますか？というと
真っ黒い四角になっちゃうんですね
そこで真っ黒い四角のフォト写真見て
何も撮られてないんじゃ？って言うんですね
認識するために心には実在するデータの刺激が必要です
カメラのフィルムと同じく
実在するデータがないと認識しないんです
フィルムは光がないと何のこともないんです
ですから ダークルームでシャッターを押しても
またあのフィルムは使えるんです
あのフィルムは認識してないんです
ですから ダークルームで
例えば 32枚撮りのフィルムを入れちゃって
ダークルームで 32枚もカチカチカチカチと押す
押したらまたリワインディングして
まあ外で写真撮れますよ
フィルムに何の反応も起きてなかったんだから
ダークルームだから だから我々の心もデータがあるならば反応を起こすんです
しかし フィルムの場合は光がなかったらそのまんまでいるんだけど
物質はそうじゃないんです
心もそうじゃないんで
いつでも変化を起こすんです
ですから 我々は音がない場合は自分で喋ろうとする
あるいは寝ることにする
あの子供は一人でいることになっちゃうと自分で歌うでしょ
お母さんが台所で忙しくて歌ってくれないんですね
子供は一人で寝たいんです
すると自分で歌うんです
自分で歌って寝るんです
で 賢いお母さんたちはね
忙しい場合は まああの子供寝るまで歌ってあげる時間ない場合はね
思い出してあげるんで
あの歌覚えてる？じゃあ言いましょうとかね
それで子供は調子に乗って覚えている歌を言うでしょうね
そのままガクンと寝ちゃうんです
だからそんな感じですよ
生命っていうのは なんで我々の心には激しい妄想の流れあるのかというと
データを埋め尽くすためなんです
見るもの 面白くない じゃあ見たくはなくなっちゃって
聞くもの面白くなくなっちゃって
退屈になると すぐ妄想
強烈な妄想の流れを作るんです
そこで見るもの あまりにも感動的でインパクト強い場合は妄想が停止するんです
まあ例えば 自分が大好きな演奏家が
もう歌手が舞台でもう派手な強烈な声
音を出してね スピーカーで踊ったり歌ったりすると
あまりにもインパクトすごいんだから
今日晩御飯何食べようかなとかはないんです
その時は 明日仕事も残ってますけど
あれはどうしようかとか
何の悩みもその時ないんです
あの妄想が なぜならば
この音と視覚データがインパクトありすぎ強すぎ
それ演奏会終わって電車に乗ったらもうインパクトが少ないでしょ
もう頭の中で再現するんですね
あれ 演奏会は あのかっこよかった
こんなかっこよかったとかね
もし仲間 3人 4人で帰るならば
また歌ってるんです それが妄想の世界で
だから我々の心はいつでもあるものにしがみすぎて引っかかっているんです
あるという現象に データがない場合はね
真っ黒を認識するはずなんです
認識しないんです 面白いことがあるんですよ
我々は目が光みたいみたいでしょ
もし我々は 1 日間 あるいは半日でもみっちりも光が入らない部屋にいるとどうなるのかと
オウム真理教でいう大号になるんです
何も光入らない真っ暗闇の部屋でいると
心が暴れるんです 情報をくれと
あえて視覚情報をくれと暴れるんです
それであらゆる幻覚が起こるんです
脳が作るんです いろんなものを見始めるで
光が見えるわ 今までをイメージした観音様が見えるわ
不動さんは見えるわ 自分たちのもうオリエンテーションによって
キリスト教の人だったらもう何か変なものは見えるわ
見えるんです しっかりとくっきりと
脳が作るんです そんなのは
だから神秘体験で宗教体験ってもう第五に達するのはとっても簡単なんです
だからこれアムションもその方法を使っているし
真如苑もその方法を使っているし
あの オウム真理教もその方を使っていたし
いろいろそういうインチキ宗教組織でやるものは
大体この暗い部屋に入れたりとかね
音が入らないところに入れたりとかね
なんとかするんです それは絶食修行とか何とか言ってね
それで頭がイカれちゃいます
それで ああ ほら よかったですねとかね
やっぱりこの先生様こそが仏様で
もうすごいんですよとかね
永久的に落とし穴に落ちてしまうんです
宗教 キリスト教も同じなんですよ
変なことをよくやってます
精神的にイカれていただくために
それが神秘体験とかね
もう神の実在すると あのエクスペリエンスオブガーッドとかね
プレゼンスオブガーッドっていうんですね
プレゼンスオブガーッドとかね
なんとか言ってるんです
それでそういうところで私にも質問するんだから
いろいろああいう各宗教でもね
それなりの経験があるでしょうにとかね
公で質問するされるとね
まあいや 困るんで返事できんだからね
頭イカれただけなんです
時々特別に個人的に話があるんだそうと言って
ある人がね もう誰かさんがね
観音さんと話し合ってるんだと
だからそういうこともありますからね
あんたね ちょっと観音がいないって言ったってもね
もしかするといるんじゃないと
私にとってはどうにも言えないんでしょうに
そのそんなに内密に話を聞くと
なんとか政治的にごまかして返さなくちゃいかんだけど
はっきり答え出せばイカれてるだけでしょうにと
なんで薬飲まないのかと
だから厳密に分析してみると
我々の心はあるということをずっと認識しっぱなしで
このデータがなくなっちゃうと暴れちゃってすぐ作るんです
その能力は心にあるんです
それでないということになっちゃうと
心はものすごく不安になるんです
で 混乱するんです 嫌なんです
それが あの こういう例で考えてください
皆様方は まあまあ この講演終わって早く終わればありがたいんですけど
そうならないみたいですけど
まだ5分ですからね で
家に帰ったところでドアを開けたら何もなかったならばどうする
です 何にもない 家にいた人々もないし
品物も家具も何もない
ただ空き家だったらどうする？どれぐらい不安になりますか？ちょっとイメージしてください
どれぐらい怖くなりますかと
例えば家族人がいたとしましょう
いっぱい荷物はもう入るのもやっとのところまで荷物いっぱいありましたと
それ何もなく空だったら
想像できないでしょ その時どんな反応すればいいかとも
それぐらいです ないということは認識しちゃうと
もう恐ろしく心が暴れるんです
だからこれは認識不可能です
心配しないでください
ないってことは認識不可能です
我々はマイナスあるは認識します
それもあるなんです 結局は
それで煩悩が生まれるんです
あの ある 例えばダイヤがあるというと
ものすごい欲が生まれてくる
プライドやら見栄やら傲慢
全部生まれるんですね
そのダイヤがなくなったら
あるものがなくなったんでしょ
そうすると 怒りやらものすごく怖くなって
怯えて震えて煩悩が生まれるんです
だからこの反対の煩悩が生まれるんです
ある時楽しいならば ない時は悲しい
ある時悲しいならば ない時は楽しい
例えば金がないということは悲しい言葉なんですね
なぜならば あるはずの金がない
と悲しい 金があるというと楽しい
そういうことで 煩悩というものがこの 2つに
いや  3つに分けられますけど
一応あの 反対の煩悩が生まれるだけ
ですから 我々は決してないということを認識しようとしないんです
こんなやばいこと こんな怖いことはやりたくはないんです
皆さん 相当哲学者でしょ？知らなかったでしょ
しかし 皆さんは一人一人間違ってでもないということは認識しようとしなかったでしょ
ということは ないということをすごい不安だと知っていたんじゃない
はい 哲学 宗教 宗教もあるの話だけですよ
もうは不安と混乱を招くのでのみで人々を安定させようとするんです
宗教っていうのは まあどんな宗教でも
もう気持ち悪いほどあるという話なんですね
我はブッダの再誕でありとかね
よくもノコノコと言うんだからね
ブッダっていうのはもう二度と生まれませんよと
もう 100回も 200回
300回ももう言ったのに
これで極限に行かれた人が現れてくるんですね
メガラマニアメーニアという病気で
精神病気にかかっている人が
それで我はブッダの再誕でありと言うと
大勢のすごく頭の人々はね
信仰するんです その通り
その通りだ ということで
だから宗教というものは
この巨大化してあるということ
解きすすくんです 神を信じる世界でも
何でも神 神 神ばっかしで
神が 24時間ずっと見張ってるんだと
それが気持ち悪いと思いますけど
ありがたく思ってるんですよ
だってオナラもできんだからね
神が見ているところにそんなこと言ったら
これ自体冒涜でしょうに
だから神を信仰する人はみんな地獄に落ちますよ
知らない 私は だって神に隠れて何もできんでしょ
神の前で身を極めて 女性だったらまあ女性の体を見ると神が興奮しますから
体をきれいに隠して 丁寧な言葉を使わなくちゃあかんでしょうに
これ 20時間見張ってるんだからね
相当暇人でしょうね 神は
はい で そこまでこのあまりにも屁理屈なのに
みんななんで信仰するのかというと
そこまで我々の理性がね
欠けているんです そこまで我々はあるということに執着しているんです
もう一つ矛盾がありますよ
ものがあるならば執着する必要ないんです
もってあるんだから では皆様
執着するものをちょっと考えてください
財布にあるお金には執着するでしょう
しかし この部屋に執着しますか？執着しないね
なぜ 財布にお金はなくなる可能性ありますけど
この部屋はね なくならんでしょ？まあ一応
一応 だからなくならないというものには執着しません
する必要ないんです だから皆様は
皆様の家がマイホームがあるならば
まあそんなにもマイホーム守ってやれそうってことよりも
あの手帳と財布は大事にするでしょうに
出かける場合は玄関の鍵はかけるでしょう
なんで家丸ごとにチェーンで鍵かけておかないんですかね
それは持っていかないと知ってるでしょ
しかし 玄関の鍵を忘れちゃうと
中のものを持っていく可能性ありますね
だから結局なくなるんだから執着しているでしょうに
なのにこのバカどもたちはなくなるということは認めないんですね
あるあるだったら執着する必要ないんです
しかし 事実は変えられませんだからね
我々はいくら踏ん張っても地球が丸いでしょうに
太陽は東から上がるでしょうに
だから事実には逆らう事実はどうにもならんです
事実はなくなるんだということなんです
あるだけじゃないんだよと
ないもありますよと だからないを理解しないで
その代わりに執着する
お金がなくなるんだっていうことを理解しないで
なくなったら大変だということで貯金するわ
いろいろ 執着するんです
それで宗教はこの極限に執着する道を教えているんです
永遠な神がいる 執着しなさいよと
奴隷になりなさいよと
それで安定させるんですね
ない場合は興奮しますから
あると言われたらすごく落ち着くんです
例えば必ず人が死ぬでしょ
嫌なんですね それが ですから
いえ 天に召されますと
言われると ああ よかったと
だったら早く死ねと言いたいんですけど
死んだら天国に神様が連れて行くならばね
早く死んだ方がいいでしょうに
まあ生きていたってもどうったことないでしょうに
だからどこまでもういい加減でバカかということなんです
人間というのは どこまで矛盾ですかと
何の何でこの矛盾に気づかないんですかね
永遠不死 天国 地獄などの話は宗教の前提です
ほとんどの哲学も有の管轄です
無を中心にする思考は少ないんです
あの たまに無について語る人々もいます
しかし この哲学の種類はすっごく少ない
例えば 存在を語る 神のことを語る哲学はたくさんありますけど
虚無主義でいえば一個しかないんです
ニヒリズムといえば一個しかないんです
いるんだけど 数少ないんです
バリエーションはないんです
神の場合はたくさんバリエーションの哲学があるんです
人間の魂のは何たることやと言っちゃうと
たくさんのバリエーションの哲学があるんです
魂がないんだよと言った途端
哲学は一個で終わっちゃうんです
その哲学者語っている虚無主義
ニヒリズム ノーシズム
アグノスティシズムという無神
無知 なんとか論とかね
ありますけど そういうのはそれほどたくさんないんです
それも結局は現実の否定のみ
彼らも彼らも無を知ったわけじゃないんです
ニヒリストが 虚無主義者が目に見えるものを否定しているだけ
日本人が一生懸命神社に行って
もう 100円あげてお祈りする場合は
それを馬鹿にしているだけ
そういう風に虚無主義っていうのは
例えば道徳を語る道徳を馬鹿にする
で 虚無主義者はあれもこれもなんでもいない
なんでもないって平気で言うんだけど
あるものを見て否定するだけなんですね
大したことないんですよ
だからバリエーションもないんです
うん